[Music]
joining me this week is an author a
radio host a television personality the
founder of the blaze calm and a man who
everyone seems to have a strong opinion
about glad back
welcome to the Rubin report how are you
I'm doing well we just chatted for two
or three minutes yeah where we started
you are one of these guys that you just
say the name Glenn Beck you just say
your name people go completely bananas
I'm going way or another yeah how does
that feel I don't deserve either of them
yeah I don't deserve the the vitriolic
ate and I don't deserve the the
adoration it's weird because because a I
don't feel like I deserve either of them
but I'm willing to take the bad I'm
willing to sit and listen to the people
who have the bad to say about me but
some of it I understand their
perspective some of it I made huge
mistakes just wrong on but I'm willing
to take my share of what has what we're
now living and in hopes that other
people will go okay wait a minute what
it what have I done to even just a
Facebook post yeah what am i doing to
contribute to the incivility that we
have I had a bigger platform but we all
have one yeah well I'm glad you
mentioned a Facebook post because now we
live in a time where someone absolutely
hate you or absolutely loves you and as
you said you may not deserve either one
of those they can get to you and then
gradient ly is that great or is it
maddening or it's both probably know if
it's reasoned yes fantastic I mean I've
done radio this is in March will be my
fortieth year in broadcast done it for
forty years when I did it to get into
radio you had to have a test and get a
license I mean it was it was hard to get
a job and there's only a small pool
people that could do it now everybody
has the same voice if you have something
that is appealing
there's no gates you have to go through
you can now you can now write the
president you can tweet he might read it
and retweet it right okay so everybody
has the opportunity to have their voice
heard that is miraculous and a chance
for me to write to the president or to
Elon Musk or anybody and have them
respond to me is truly remarkable yeah
what we're missing is but because you
have that power
it also requires responsibility and
because I did radio for 40 years and my
radio worldview was really shaped during
the beginnings of Howard Stern and I
mean the early Washington before he
anybody knew him yeah Howard Stern I was
raised in that era of of stunting and
you know entertainment and what I did
was I mixed the to trouble trouble and I
didn't see a problem is a natural
evolution that has taught a whole
generation of that's the way you do it
yeah not good I remember watching you
when you were on Fox News and you know
you have the board and you're drawing
arrows everywhere talking about the
government this and gods here and people
are replacing government and Brooklyn
and all this stuff and I remember being
half entertained half I was like wow
this guy's nuts I can't believe this is
on television and then half going
there's actual information here so when
you were when you started doing that
stuff that you was that really the goal
like I'm going to do a little bit of
everything
and then we'll figure out that sausage
so my my job as I saw it was to get
ratings that's my job to get ratings
people forget that like that should be
overlooked right there at the end of the
day you have to get ratings you have to
get
how many people now keep checking their
Facebook page to see how many likes they
get I mean moms at home how many likes
do I get right it's the same thing and
if you're not careful you'll find
yourself caught up in those likes yeah
early in my life out being an alcoholic
before I sobered up I do anything for a
rating point that drove me rating points
success money fame yeah I crashed thank
God for that crash or I would have
probably still be at Fox and I get
monster
but the crash taught me that that can
help you on goals don't let it control
you so yes my first part my job was to
get ratings right but that was just a
vehicle for me to be able to have my
point of view and perspective and my
perspective was the early 20th century
progressive is extraordinarily dangerous
you may not be that person today but the
roots are this and some are still those
people okay and that's what you were
drawing really or a lot often talking
about the role of government a lot of
things that I Scott's on this show you
were saying it starts here correct and
this is where it's going to end correct
and so to you know I did like three
shows on Woodrow Wilson and they were
number one yeah
beating prime time I did Hayek a whole I
think a week on Hayek which put Road to
Serfdom back on the top 10 New York
Times bestseller list yeah and it was a
rating success so my job was how do I
make it interesting make it fun make it
entertaining and really teach something
that no one else says can be taught on
TV yeah how many of the people that
someone that's been in cable news now
you're on the frontier of the digital
stuff how many people that we actually
watch in cable news do you really think
know what they're talking about this is
something that I'm finding more and more
often there are so few people when I
turn on the television any of the cable
news channel to spare
I think this person really is sort of
intellectually honest or really
understand what the role of government
is or or any of that stuff or are they
just television people and we should
just view them that way most of them are
television people remember the lady
Paula Zahn
yeah guard okay this is early on in my
career and who was it Anna Nicole
Smith's remember she committed suicide
yeah so I was first on every producers
rolodex to call when there was a suicide
because I have suicided my family and
alcoholism call Glenn Beck he knows yeah
and she didn't think to have on your
resume I know I know I guess um but it
used to happen every time the star would
off themselves or have a drug problem
right um you know Robert Downey quit
called land and so she didn't really
know who I was she just knew that I knew
about alcoholism and I was alcoholic and
her question was so insipid it was hella
could we have done to prevent this like
as an alcoholic
nothing yeah everybody has their own
bottom nothing but I'll never forget I
started talking about my mother she has
some question and it got to my mother
suicide I had not talked about it on
national Airways and when we were
talking and I was trying to really
explain to her that what alcoholism
really is to me that it's not something
that somebody can talk you out of it she
had no interest it was like a fog the
minute I started talking about my
suicide I are my mother's suicide I saw
her eyes all of a sudden like the gears
went he might cry yeah ratings Oh she
was locked and interested but only to
try to make me cry to get a ratings
point you know I was so crazy and awful
and I remember walking off feeling dirty
and I have met very few I could count
them on one hand very few truly
intellectually curious yeah and honest I
think the only one that I can say is
intellectually curious and really tries
to be intellectually on
Anderson Cooper hmm guy don't agree with
but I get along with really well yeah he
really tries really tries to get it
right I don't think he does but he tries
and it bothers him when he doesn't we
don't have to do the rolodex of all the
people but I'm curious let me think
about Don Lemon he's a friend of mine
he's been on the show I liked I I saw
you guys together cut you did I think
back-to-back nights what was about a
year ago right and yeah you guys really
F yeah whatever [ __ ] me you did
something whatever I guess but I thought
it was really great because it wasn't
gotcha news it was a little more of what
I try to do here which is a decent talk
yeah from people that may or may not
have different perspective do you think
basically he's sorta image yeah I think
I don't I don't you know him like I know
Anderson personally yeah and so I don't
know Don personally I know him on the
air and I know when he's on with me yeah
it's always intellectually curious and
intellectually honest which I really
find really rare yeah really rare is
intellectual honesty it's really rare
but I mean is it like it's so not
rewarded anymore like this is what we
were talking about right before you
started that people forget these
politicians these news people they
forget we have YouTube we can now watch
you saying the exactly revertere thing
and that's the question does anyone even
care or is any everyone just pick their
side and that's it so you just go really
no I mean the root word of civilization
is civil and to be civil you have to
have intellectual honesty you have to be
able to say I'm sorry you have to be
able to say I was wrong you also have to
sit there and listen when somebody
else's being wrong and give them the
opportunity to say yeah sorry that was
wrong I don't know we're in a phase
right now and I think it's just a phase
if it doesn't destroy us it might you
know we might be at the circus and cakes
part of the Empire Georgia but if it
doesn't destroy us it will return one
way or another
even if it destroys us yeah it will
return and that's why I think right now
it's important for people to stand up to
do what you're doing that's not popular
it's not popular you're pissing off the
people that used to know you know and
correct me if I'm wrong know they're
pissed at me yeah right but a certain
amount of them have you changed now or
have you held on to the same principles
and the world has moved you know it's so
funny I keep saying that my liberal
principles are now becoming a
conservative position and I think I've
had a little bit of an evolution I'm
probably a little more small-government
than I used to be but the basic liberal
tenants that I've had are the exact same
things that I had probably literally 20
liberal Union classic I mean classical
liberals not progressive and I yeah I go
out of my way every week to try to
explain the difference of that huge and
unfortunately the word liberal has just
been mangled to the point where people
don't understand what that is I or
progressives for a reason got to take
the individual freedom chair away from
the table if you look at the early
progressive movement with Wilson and oh
god here I go yeah go no is Wilson and
Theodore Roosevelt they both believed in
the big state where does the person who
says no I don't want state both party
said no it's state it's either and this
is before these took on dirty names
it's either fascism or communism which
one is it fascism or communism that was
the argument and the people that said no
no no constitutionalism individual
freedom my own choice my own way of
doing it No yeah so FDR co-opted the
word liberal named the the right
conservative and that took the
conservative that said I believe in the
constituency man's freedom I'm a classic
liberal it made that go away yeah took
that choice away so now we have to do
what the opposite of what the
progressives did and retrain people say
no they they they they hijacked those
words to take what we all feel amazing
these words now
her they always just sounded nice but
they have never rung as real to me as
they do now there are some things that
we find self-evident that all men are
created equal and they have certain
rights yeah and their life liberty and
the pursuit of happiness it doesn't
belong to the government yeah
it also doesn't belong to any other
nation which is interesting nobody has
that the pursuit of happiness
written in their constitutionally we
have that we haven't always lived up to
it in terms of the quality in the
resident but it's a problem the college
system the pursuit of happiness
is one that I think Thomas Jefferson
would have argued harder against had he
known how it would be twisted because he
originally wrote it life liberty and
property but because they were
anti-slavery right they knew if you put
property there then it's going to be
taken for slaves they'll say the South
slaves these are properties guaranteed
right here in the Declaration of
Independence our founding document so
they changed it to life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness imagine if that
word would have been just left alone and
been property we're a million miles away
from that yeah no man has the right to
take anything from me I love that you
mentioned Thomas Jefferson because I
think he's the best example of someone
that lived in a time where what they
believed in didn't quite match up to
their life so this is a guy I was at
Monticello about a year ago I've told
the story a couple of times where they
give you the tour and they fully I was
incredibly impressed what they do they
admit he had slaves oh yeah they admit
that he slept with at least one slave
they that's dicey they pretty much
admitted it but yeah but I know but
there's you should ask them for the
evidence because the evidence I think
they mentioned her name and yes Ella
Hammond yeah yeah but that was proven
for about three weeks and it was done by
Joseph Ellis he misstated that they have
his evidence that it could be one of 36
Jefferson's they need his actual DNA
and it was known at the time that his
brother I think was sleeping with the
slaves so the paper evidence of the time
shows that it was most likely his
brother Joseph Ellison back in the 90s
was the one who wrote the book American
Sphinx and he said it was Thomas right
that was disproven three weeks later the
genealogists came out and said no no we
didn't say that we said it could be one
of 36 Jefferson's so they're still argue
you should talk to people over in
Monticello because I think they're
giving a yeah less nuance but but my
point being that it shows how we all
live in sort of conflicted lives yeah
while he owned slaves he was writing the
laws to free slate yeah yeah he didn't
free his slaves immediately but again
here's something we also leave out of
the history books Thomas Jefferson went
to Williamsburg
several times to to propose the
legislation that you could release your
slaves if you were in debt which he was
I'm sure they told you about his wine
collection area if you were in debt
you could not free your slaves okay I
think even upon death you couldn't do it
it's they finally changed the death part
but that's why Washington and Jefferson
were anti-slavery having slaves
Jefferson couldn't release them because
of debt Washington did it because the
law only allowed him to do it on death
yeah I don't even mention it to judge
him in that way as well I know to show
that we all live with strange forces we
are all glad we're all going to be
remembered at this time there's going to
be something yeah I don't know what it
is
but there's going to be something that
they're going to go what hypocrites know
it we're doing the best we can you know
it's funny I Seinfeld is still in my
favorite sitcom of all time and every
night that I'm watching it seven o'clock
web bribe dinner I'm watching and I
think man in ten years the pitchforks
are going to come after the show because
every episode dealt with some strange
racial thing or religious thing or
economic thing or something and it's
like that's that's
issue with the professors now if you
don't change the second they do now
you're a homophobe you're racist you're
a big a drama bah bah bah bah let's put
all that aside for a moment and start
which was with the first question that I
wanted to ask I take on my outside oh
he's just that please that happens on
the right - yeah give me give me this
give me honey it happens on the right -
if you're not the right religion or
you're not falling in the right box on X
Y & Z Rand Paul libertarian Pro gay
marriage uh I was I can't say it was Pro
gay marriage
I'm Pro do what you want - you're Pro
Liberty I'm Pro Liberty I am a religious
guy who believes marriage is something
between a man and woman for the
procreation of children that's what I
believe
you don't believe that okay what's the
problem
right so saying that two people on the
right there's a lot alike well then
you're not a conservative yeah then
you're not you're not a Christian er
you're not this you're not that we both
do it yeah let's stop it we should stop
it
[Music]
you
[Music]